manger local en été quand on habite dans
une région de production maraîchère
c'est un défi qui est assez facile à
relever mais sous certaines latitudes
même pendant la belle saison les
récoltes sont maigres
voilà pourquoi la solidarité et
l'ingéniosité peuvent aider à remplir le
panier d'épicerie
cultiver des tomates en serre
ou des choux comme le chou quel ou
encore des oignons en chant n'a rien de
bien extraordinaire sauf quand on le
fait ici à longue-pointe-de-mingan en
pleine côte nord dans un océan
d'épinettes
nous sommes vers le 50e parallèle
presqu'au niveau de la baie james ne va
pas avoir d'équivalent de jardin de
produits de production maraîchère
diversifiée plus à laisser plus au nord
à notre connaissance en tout cas on
espère une découvrir s'il y en a un
cachet encore plus au nord
la ferme s'appelle le grenier boréale
une coopérative de solidarité fondée en
le sol ici n'est vraiment pas fait pour
l'agriculture c'est une mince couche
d'humus sur lit de sable lui même
reposant sur du tuf imperméable le seul
recenser les grosses galettes saison
comme larouche ses jeux sur 4,5
par endroits le fait qu'elle ait aucune
racine qui peut pénétrer un insolent
comme ça puis des fois on a juste
suppose de sol avec l'idée ça a été
vraiment devenir le cas c'est
mécaniquement qu'une pelle mécanique
pour ensuite reprendre tout le végétal
qui le remettent par dessus l'autre
obstacle de taille c'est le vent ces
grands tunnels ont été emportés par la
bourrasque
un coup dur qui ne s'oublie pas ç'a déjà
arraché qu'un mal et on attache
notamment tous n'ont qu'un camp normand
sa structure du tunnel fait exceptionnel
pas c'est tout
tarik en reste un peu c'est un peu
décourageant
depuis les tunnels ont été déplacées
plus bas dans un champ bien entouré
d'arbres
[Musique]
autre problème les engrais il n'ya pas
d'élevage aux alentours alors on doit se
débrouiller avec les moyens du bord les
copeaux de bois par exemple ou même des
produits de la mer les a glissé ses
possibles sont belles ressources
on peut apprendre les ice bar de la mère
faisait avec ceux traditionnellement les
gens ils faisaient du goût hamas fx
tornade fermenté des salles et puis des
sables et par l'eau en plus des légumes
courant la coopérative test des cultures
plus rares mais rustiques comme cérences
arctique par exemple où ces fraises
blanchâtre qui goûte la nana quand elles
sont bien mûres si une plante qui est un
excellent couvre-sol nous on est en
train de faire un test à savoir sont pas
des arbustes fruitiers une deuxième
strate avec un couvre-sol qui donne qui
donnent des fruits
[Musique]
cette deuxième strate est elle aussi
rustique bien sûr c'est la camerise un
autre essai
qu'on voulait et allait avoir un fruit
qui arrive avant la fraise avec la camry
c1 et plus des plus actifs ont souhaité
hier la fraise puis on a implanté aussi
cette année une framboise hier pour
avoir des fruits
après quand on arrête toute la saison du
touquet autres on a même planté du
houblon à la demande d'une micro
brasseries locales et même des années ou
bon on avait des melons les gens
croyaient pas que les mâles on avait
poussé ici parce que bon et ça blaguait
un peu amusant vous avez sûrement pris
ça l'ex rennais annonce a poussé
effectivement dans les tunnels ici en
2010 est le grenier boréal a remporté le
prix action david suzuki qui récompense
les projets ayant un impact positif sur
l'environnement et les communautés
david suzuki lui même est venu le
remettre à la coopérative et on était
très très très heureux puisque c'était
même la première visite de monsieur est
unique et dans la région de la côte-nord
la coopérative est en pleine expansion
on est en train d'agrandir la superficie
cultivée et on va bientôt bâtir un
nouvel entrepôt
les produits sont vendus au kiosque de
la ferme dans les marchés locaux et par
le système des paniers acheté à l'avant
ce dont on les appelait pagny boréale
parce qu'il ya des produits maraîchers
mais il y aussi des produits de fruits
dans des trucs qui viennent aussi la
forêt boréale
aujourd'hui on livre à
havre-saint-pierre
[Musique]
on va chez anthony cormier un
administrateur de la coopérative
particulièrement convaincu de la
pertinence de greny boréale début de la
vague
accésss et trouvent un moyen pour faire
gros c est cette vague fidèles de la
rendent le plus gros qu'on peut pour
atteindre le pesage impossible
visiblement les fraises blanche et les
ronces arctique ont du succès jambes
blanc laventure du grenier boréale en
est à sa septième année d'existence
ça donne envie à certains de développer
des jardins des jardins communautaires
des projets qui se développe comme ça
tranquillement un peu un peu soutenue
par le milieu municipal où que ce soit
par des organisations communautaires
il ya un intérêt de développer ça le
fait qu'on existe ça permet aux gens de
se projeter de deux de se rendre compte
que c'est possible en fait trop
[Musique]